[ Cheers and applause ]
-♫ Search party ♫
-Playing tonight,
we have the Tim McGraw party!
♫♫
[ Cheers and applause ]
And their opponents,
the Faith Hill party.
♫♫
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right.
First up, we have Tim and Faith.
Come on down.
- Go, good luck, good luck.
You can do it, you can do it.
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here´s how the game works.
How are you?
Good to see you.
-How you doing?
Nice to see you.
-Fantastic.
How are you, Tim?
-Hey, how are you doing?
Nice to see you.
-You guys know each other.
That´s not good.
We´re opposite teams, man.
-No fraternizing.
-Here´s how the game works.
I will read you the start
of an Internet search...
-Oh, Lord.
-...and you fill in the blank.
-Oh, Lord, geez.
-We have the top four most
popular answers on the board.
You´ll both type in your answers
as fast as you can on --
This is called a computer.
-Okay.
-And then we´ll see --
-He knows what a computer is.
-If it matches the top four --
-Barely.
-...top four answers --
And here´s the first search.
Ready?
-Oh, Lord. Okay.
-Why do country singers
always sing about blank?
Now type in your blank.
-Come on, Faith.
You can do it. Type it!
Tell me when you´re locked in.
-I´m locked in.
-Yeah, locked in?
Is everybody locked in?
-I´m locked in.
-Locked in.
-Okay, Faith,
what did you write?
-Love.
-Love?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Good answer!
-Nice answer.
-Tim, what did you write?
-D-I-V-O-R-C-E.
-Oh, nice!
Divorce.
Let´s see if we have
any matches.
♫♫
Yeah!
-The number-one answer!
-Faith, get on over there!
We´re gonna go to Faith´s team.
-That´s great!
Come on, we did it, we did it.
Hello, darling.
-Hey.
Oh, my God.
Hi, Mr. Dawson.
-Once again,
name the most popular word
that completes the search,
Jimmy.
Why do country singers
always sing about blank?
What is it?
-Mama?
[ Laughter ]
-Let´s see mama!
Ooh!
[ Audience groans ]
-One fail.
-What?
-Two fails, and you´re out.
-That is not cool.
-James, it´s up to you.
Come on.
Why do country singers
about blank?
Why do they sing about...?
-Drinking.
-Drinking!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
Let´s see drinking.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay, Faith.
-Yes.
You always sing about...
-Um...
[ Chuckles ]
Uh, my -- my family.
-Yes, family.
-Family.
-I love family.
-Okay.
If they get family, you win.
If not, the McGraw steals it.
Ready?
Let´s see it.
Ooh!
[ Audience groans ]
That´s two.
Tariq.
Tariq Trotter.
-Hey. How you doing?
-Famed entrepreneur.
-Yep, yep.
-Country singers.
-Yeah.
-They often sing about what?
-We often sing about, uh...
-We?
[ Laughter ]
-You´re not a country singer.
-The line between country and
hip-hop has been blurred.
-You´re right, you´re right.
Blurred lines.
-Yeah.
-I´m gonna say trucks.
-Trucks!
Let´s see trucks!
Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my gosh!
You guys won that one.
-All right, they got one.
-Now we´re gonna start again.
Jimmy?
-What was the last answer?
-Let´s see.
What´s that number-four answer?
Dogs.
-Yeah, yeah, dogs.
-All right, Jimmy and Tariq,
get up here.
♫♫
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on, Jimmy.
-All right, ready?
Speaking of dogs...
-Come on, Jimmy.
-Yes.
-Why do dogs blank?
Why do dogs blank?
Tell me when
you´re both locked in.
Internet search.
People queried the Internet.
Ask Jeeves.
What does Jeeves have to say?
[ Laughter ]
-That doesn´t exist anymore.
-What´s that?
-Ask Jeeves.
-I got an assistant.
I don´t know what
the Internet looks like.
Jimmy, what did you write?
-I wrote, bark.
Why do dogs --
"Why do dogs bark?"
Nice.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tariq?
-That´s a good answer.
-I got it right.
-You got a good answer.
I said, "Why do dogs run away?"
-Oh, Tariq that´s sad.
-Run away?
That´s sad.
-My dog --
-Wow.
-Your dogs run away from you?
-I´m still thinking about
country-western songs.
-Oh, okay, there you go.
We´ve moved on.
Let´s see what we´ve got!
♫♫
Bark, number-one answer!
-I´m sorry, I´m sorry.
-Oh, my gosh!
It´s a barn burner.
It´s time for you guys to steal.
-Run away.
I love my dog in my house.
Why do dogs spoon?
Why do dogs spoon with me?
-Are they dry?
-James.
-Why do dogs sniff?
-Sniff!
-Oh, nice.
-We´re not gonna say what.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Sniff. Let´s see sniff.
♫♫
Sniff butts!
I didn´t say that.
-Sniff butts!
-That´s your first movie!
-That was my first movie.
-I played James Butts.
-You were great in that.
-And you played Gary Sniff.
-Gary Sniff Butts.
We were a detective team.
I remember.
-Sniff ´n´ Butts.
-All right, Faith,
Why do dogs do...?
-Since we´re on butts, um, poop.
´Cause everybody poops.
-They do. That is true.
That is a fact.
[ Applause ]
Let´s hear it for poop!
-It´s a book.
-It´s a book, it´s a book!
-I know.
-The only thing
that would make me happier
is if it was
the number two answer.
-Ah!
-Let´s see -- why do dogs poop?
Let´s see poop!
-Ooh!
-There´s no poop up there.
-This is rigged. So rigged.
-Why do dogs...?
-Dogs do what?
-Dogs do a lot of things.
-They do.
Oh, I know.
Go ahead.
[ Laughter ]
-No, let´s just --
Let´s just get in the zone
for a second.
Maybe I can...
why do dogs howl?
-Howl. Owl?
-Wait.
-Yes!
He said it.
He said it!
-Let´s see howl!
-All right.
-Quest.
-They got it?
-Okay.
-We´re going to you, baby.
-Why do dogs bite?
-Good answer.
-Bite!
Let´s see bite!
Ooh!
No, we gotta run.
That means Team Faith wins!
James, Quest, get up here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♫♫
-You got it.
-Okay.
This is the final round.
-Hoo!
-The final round.
For 8 million points.
Name a word
that completes this search.
How do I get more blank?
-James, be careful.
-James, come on.
-Oh, dear.
-You got it?
You know what it is?
-This is up to James.
-James has got it?
-I´m locked in.
[ Laughter ]
-That´s a good one.
That´s a good one.
-I have a feeling
this is gonna be filthy.
You locked in?
Are you locked in?
-Yeah.
-All right.
James.
-Money.
-Yes.
-That´s a nice one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Satisfaction.
[ Laughter ]
What?
-How do I get more satisfaction?
Let´s see it!
♫♫
Money!
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right.
Faith, we´re gonna start
with you.
-Oh, that´s not a good idea.
-How do I get more blank?
-Um, yes, uh...
How do I get more --
-♫ Yes, sir ♫
-♫ Yes, sir,
how do I get more ♫
♫ Oww ♫
[ Cheers and applause ]
How do I get --
How do I get more, uh,
intelligence.
I don´t know.
-Yes.
-I know --
-Let´s see intelligence.
-It´s not up there.
I know. I´m sorry.
-Okay.
-I´m sorry, team.
-No, please.
My answer --
How do I get more --
I want to say guac,
but I´m not gonna say it.
I´m not gonna say it.
-Guac is not your answer.
-How do I get --
How do I get more time?
-Time!
-Oh, that´s a good answer.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let´s see time.
[ Audience groans ]
-What?
-Now it´s up to you guys
for the steal.
-We can steal it.
-You can steal it.
If you steal, you win.
-What?
-If you steal it, you win.
-The whole game?
-One answer.
-Are you allowed
to talk to each other?
-One answer. They´re just
gonna get one answer.
-Yes, we are.
-If they get this right,
they win.
If they get it wrong, they lose.
One answer.
You guys ready?
-Yeah.
-Oh, wait!
-Okay, ready?
How do I get more...?
-One, two, three.
-Sex.
[ Laughter ]
-Let´s see sex!
Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
The winner!
Team Tim!
-The worst!
Unbelievable!
My thanks to Tim McGraw,
the champ!
Tariq Trotter, Questlove!